c'est notre voisin le plus proche
le second objet le plus brillant de
notre ciel nous savons que la lueur de
la lune est un reflet du rayonnement du
soleil et que des hommes ont marché sur
sa surface
pourtant la lune est toujours un mystère
d'où vient-elle
pourrions nous y vivre
pour tenter de percer le mystère de
notre seul satellite naturel
nous devons voyager vers d'autres
planètes et d'autres satellites
à la limite du système solaire la
planète plutôt et son satellite charron
photographie en accéléré par le
télescope à bâle
dans cette séquence simulé ils ne sont
séparés que par 19 mille kilomètres plus
tôt et la plus petite planète du système
solaire plus petit que notre lune est à
peine deux fois plus grande que charon
au sens strict du terme
charon n'est pas en orbite autour de
plus tôt ils sont tous les deux en
orbite autour de leur centre de gravité
commun doit-on parler d'une double
planète ou d'un satellite et d'une
planète
et voici un autre satellite
on pensait que seuls les planètes avait
des satellites jusqu'à ce que l'on
découvre ce rocher en orbite autour de
cet astéroïde l'astéroïde ida mesure 56
km de long et le satellite dactyle moins
de deux kilomètres
ce minuscule satellite est probablement
un morceau de l'astéroïde ida qui s'est
détachée lors d'une collision
il reste aux astronomes à déterminer si
c'est un satellite et qu'est ce que
c'est si ça n'est pas un satellite un
satellite au kiel être inactif et s'il
déborde d'activités le système solaire
est riche en satellite de toutes sortes
ni eau par exemple ou des panaches
volcaniques jaillissent à plus de 300 km
de la surface
le grand que pluton niveau est en fait
un satellite
la découverte de ces éruptions fit
sensation en 1979 quand des sondes
spatiales visiteurs jupiter
des neuf planètes du système solaire
donnons pas de satellite les deux plus
proche du soleil mercure dans la surface
et desséchée par la chaleur n'est pas
plus grande qu'un satellite
elle n'a connu aucune activité depuis
des milliards d'années
à l'opposé venus subit les tempêtes et
les remous d'un climat épouvantable mais
elle aussi voyage seul
ce n'est pas le cas des planètes géantes
voici jupiter et son cortège de
satellites
jupiter la 5e en partant du soleil la
plus grosse des planètes à quatre
satellites plus gros que pluton au total
seize satellites en orbite autour de
jupiter
vu par voyageur deux satellites et leurs
ombres
lancée en 1977 bay sands voyageurs 1 et
2 ont mis deux ans à atteindre les
satellites de jupiter
oh
voici calysto le plus extérieur des
quatre grands sa surface accidenté
constellé de prater d'impact
ouais
la formation la plus spectaculaire et
valhalla un bassin de 3000 km de
diamètre représenté sur cette vue
d'artiste
valhalla a subi l'impact d'une météorite
il ya des milliards d'années
ailleurs des cratères plus petit
recouvre dimanche sonne témoignage d'un
bombardement incessant pendant les
premiers temps du système solaire galy
ce taux est resté figé dans le temps
calisto ressemble peut-être notre lune
mais ces cratères sont brillants car ce
monde n'est qu'une boule de glace autour
d'un noyau rocheux
quittons calysto pour aller visiter
ganymède nous survolons le plus grand
satellite du système solaire il est roué
de nombreux cratères
mais aussi recouvert de rites étranges
on pense que ce sont des fractures ou
l'eau s'est infiltrée et a gelé
à moins de 230 degrés la surface de
ganymède et d'une croûte gelée de 300
kilomètres d'épaisseur en dessous un
manteau de glace entoure un noyau
rocheux au contraire de calisto ganymède
a évolué
vu de ganymède jupiter domine le ciel
jusqu'à voyageurs nous ne savions pas
que jupiter avec un anneau un halo de
poussière comme du talc
les points claire en orbite dans le plan
de la noce ont d'autres satellites de
jupiter
et voici le soleil ici ce n'est guère
plus qu'une étoile qui brille à plus
d'un demi milliard de kilomètres
le troisième satellite de jupiter par la
taille et europe
un satellite lisse comme un oeuf sa
surface ne présente aucun cratère europe
et probablement un immense océan
recouvert d'une mince couche de glace de
telles structures apparaissent aussi sur
terre là où la mer gèle et font de
manière répétée
s'il y a une autre forme de vie dans le
système solaire ce sera ici qu'on la
découvrira au 21ème siècle des sous
marins robotisés plongeront sous la
glace de cette planète pour tenter de
percer son mystère
la vie sur terre a commencé dans les
océans aujourd'hui elle continue à se
développer dans les eaux de l'arctique
et de l'antarctique alors pourquoi pas
dans les mers d'europe
c'est une perspective passionnante
si jupiter était une étoile europe
serait une planète
au lieu d'être un oeuf hermétiquement
clos seul le temps et les
astrobiologistes pourrons nous apprendre
s'il abrite une forme de vie
de tous les satellites de jupiter celui
ci est le plus exotique cio le plus
proche des 4 grands satellites callière
au début il a intrigué les savants pas
de cratères pas de glace il ressemblait
à une pizza mais les images de voyageurs
révélèrent la vérité de sa structure
géologique le rouge de ce satellite et
du soufre c'est le corps célestes qui
présente la plus intense activité
volcanique jamais observée
la surface est ponctuée d'éruption
incessantes
des volcans de la taille du colorado
crash dépannage de gaz d'une hauteur
monumental l'astre tout entier est en
pleine activité
l'activité volcanique en prennent un
remodelage incessant de la surface la
cause en est l'attraction combiné est
opposée de jupiter et europe et au
-comme une balle de tennis sans cesse
compris mais le résultat est une
extraordinaire chaleur interne et des
éruptions incessante par toutes les
fissures de la croûte
sa surface est essentiellement
constituée elle souffre
uranus la septième planète du soleil est
un géant entouré de 11 à nous ils furent
comptés lors du passage de voyageurs 2
en 1986
à cause du manque de contraste il est
difficile de voir les anneaux à partir
de la terre voyageurs à analyser leur
formation ce sont des particules de
glace aussi petit qu'un grain de
poussière ou aussi grande d'une maison
les anneaux sont peut être les restes de
satellites ayant explosé
les débris d'un impact avec un corps de
la taille de la terre
la même collision et peut être
responsable de son axe de rotation
particulière
l' axe de rotation de la planète ait
basculé de 90 degrés par rapport à la
verticale ou plan de l'orbité autour du
soleil ici le soleil et ce point de
lumière
au delà de voyageurs
un gros plan des anneaux et de quelques
7 nuls ces images ont été traités par
ordinateur
en réalité les anneaux sont noirs uranus
à 15 satellite
en 1989 la saga continue et voyageurs
atteints la lointaine neptune
personne ne savait si neptune avait des
anneaux ou seulement des arbres des
anneaux partiel voyageurs à élucider le
mystère neptune à bien des années et les
arcs ne sont que les parties plus
épaisses de celano la sonde confirma la
présence de cinq anneaux et de huit
satellites
mais ce n'était rien comparé à saturne
saturne est sans conteste le seigneur
des anneaux au début des années 80
voyageurs mis fin à des siècles de
spéculations l'astronome galibert et
observer des objets intrigue en 1610
mais ce n'est que 50 ans plus tard que
les anneaux furent identifiés en tant
que tel
jusqu'à voyageurs les astronomes
pensaient que saturne n'avait que six ou
sept à nous en fait il y as est à nos
principes ont chacun formé de centaine
d'anneaux plus petits
les marines
voyageur a non seulement prouvé que les
anneaux n'était pas solide il a aussi
identifié leur nature ils sont formés de
milliards de particules de glace un
mélange céleste qui comprend également
des silicates et de l'oxydé de fer
les images de voyageurs révélèrent les
espaces entre les anneaux principaux
l'animation montre un seul anneau
composé d'une importante quantité de
petits satellites en orbite grands comme
des voitures
en plus de ces anneaux saturne
entraînent 18 satellites
voici le plus gros titan en orbite à
plus d'un million de kilomètres du
gérant gazeux dit en présence d'une
atmosphère de brouillard orange une fois
et demie plus dense que la nôtre
titan est plus gros que mercure c'est un
monde de lacs de méthane et de neige
d'hydrocarbures comme la terre en état
de congélation avancer la composition
chimique de titan et peut-être semblable
à celle de la terre
quand la vie est apparue
au début du 21e siècle un vaisseau
spatial du nom de cassini fera route
vers saturne et ira explorer titan
cassini lâchera une sonde qui pénétrera
le linceul qui entourent titan elle
apportera des informations que voyageur
n'a pu fournir elle se posera doucement
sur la surface de la planète
la sonde analysera les possibilités
d'une colonisation futur par les hommes
revenons aux années 80 dans voyageurs
sur vos la saturn
ces petits satellites furent clairement
photographier l'un deux ans et lab
mesurait 510 km de diamètre
grâce à voyageurs nous pouvons examiner
sa double personnalité par endroits
creuset de nombreux trains ter sa
surface est d'ailleurs parfaitement
lisse de los andes avoir jailli à
travers des fissures puis avoir gelé
commeo le satellite de jupiter
il semble avoir suivi des déformations
par effets de marée
en route vers uranus et son satellite le
plus étrange
voici des photos de miranda prise par
voyageur monde au paysage déchiquetés
miranda est un exemple d'activité
géologique débrider un assemblage
hétéroclite de glaciers et de canyon est
encore plus étonnant ces falaises de
glace haute de 19 km imaginez que vous
vous teniez à leurs pieds et que vous
contant plier uranus véritable colosse
de l'espace
si un homme sauter du haut de ses
falaises est faible 1 faible gravité
il faudrait 12 minutes et 30 secondes
pour atteindre le sol
voyageur nous entraîne maintenant vers
le plus grand satellite de la vie d'une
triton grâce à leur moteur les sondes se
sont alignés soigneusement pour prendre
les meilleures photos possibles
prêtons avait l'air bizarre ouverte
d'étranges ligne entrecroisés ce sont
des éruptions geler la surface la plus
froide connu striée de lignes noires est
encore plus étrange un geyser d'azoté ça
que souligne de noir
le soleil est distant d'environ cinq
milliards de kilomètres pourtant il est
assez fort pour faire fondre la surface
gelée de triton dg d'azov grève la
croûte figé ils s'étendent sur plus de
250 kilomètres
portés par les vents et s'élève à 12 km
d'altitude
briton est extraordinaire et témoigne de
la grande variété des satellites
le système solaire en compte des
centaines
oui
nous
deux des plus petits satellites sont en
orbite autour de notre voisine mars la
planète rouge
ces satellites de mars sont peut-être
des astéroïdes capturés il mesure moins
de 24 km de diamètre
ces rochers en forme de pomme de terre
s'appelle phobos et deimos dans les
années 80 les soviétiques envoyèrent 2
vaisseau pour explorer la surface de
phobos
hélas il ne l'atteignait jamais
pourtant ils réussirent à prendre
quelques photos
au cours du 21e siècle des hommes
explorons mars quand ils repartiront
faut bosser des mots sur serviront
peut-être de relais au cours de leur
voyage
notre satellite la lune est d'une grande
placidité comparé à d'autres satellites
plus exotique la lune est d'une taille
moyenne
le disque lunaire n'est pas plus grand
que les états unis elle présente
toujours la même face à la terre et nous
ne voyons jamais son autre phase donc
même quand une seule partie de la lune
et éclairé nous voyons toujours les
mêmes formations au même endroit
oh
la lune est stérile inerte et dépourvue
de tout atmosphère pendant la journée
les températures grimpent à 120 degrés
et la nuit
elle tombe à 120 degrés en dessous de
zéro
l'exploration de la lune a commencé en
1994 une minuscule sondes clémentine à
cartographier ces surfaces comme jamais
auparavant
en
voici les photos prises par clémentine
alors que la sonde de tourner en orbite
autour de la lune
nous survolons le prater antonia dit
creusée par un impact de météorite il y
à presque 4 milliards d'années
antonia des mesures 1160 km de diamètre
d'autres cratère plus petits ont été
creusées dans cette paroisse préserver
dans le vide de l'espace
à l'abri du vent et de l'eau
où
survolant le pôle sud de la lune
clémentine a pris ces photos en accéléré
en gros plan ouvrez de longmont pour dit
on en suivant la rotation de la lune sur
son axe elles sont projetés par le
soleil sur le relief de la lune
un autre vaisseau spatial galileo a
profité d'un effet des langues
gravitationnelles entre la lune et la
terre pour gagner de l'impulsion dans
son voyage vers jupiter
au cours de son périple galileo nous a
offert une nouvelle perspective les
premières images de la terre de la lune
se déplaçant ensemble dans l'espace
galileo et clémentine ont tous les deux
pris des images de la lune avec des
équipements spéciaux une fois colorier
ces images montrent les différents
minéraux à la surface de la lune un
guide pour les futurs prospecteurs qui
un jour c'est certain exploiteront la
lune
clémentine nous a donné les premières
vues détaillées des régions polaires de
la lune grâce aux ordinateurs
nous pouvons survolé ces zones obscures
comme presque toute la surface de la
lune les pôles sont creusées de cratères
témoignages des tirs de météorites et
d'astéroïdes qui ont bombardé le système
solaire au début de son existence la
lune elle même et peut-être ce qui reste
d'une collision avec la terre voisine et
nouvellement formés
aucun homme ne s'est posé sur la lune
depuis les missions apollo
mais au 21ème siècle de nouveaux
explorateurs viendront de la terre
notre première base permanente dans
l'espace sera sur la lune sur la face
cachée de la lune
des astronomes et des radioastronomes
établiront une base idéale pour leurs
observations à l'abri des distorsions
causées par la terre
oh
un jour dans des dizaines d'années nous
enverrons des vaisseaux sur les
satellites des autres planètes nous
irons nous promener surpris dont se
délite je les ai nous admirerons la
planète neptune
et à la limite ultime de notre système
nous résoudrons le mystère de pluton est
ce une double planète où une petite
planète avec un gros satellite ou le
seront au 21ème siècle lorsque les
premières sondes atteindront ces régions
reculées
on
e